bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france merci
d'être avec nous pour quelles raisons
est-ce que vous jugé injuste ce nouveau
mode de calcul pour les demandeurs
d'emploi eh bien nous sommes extrêmement
surpris de la décision du conseil d'état
qui
se contredit lui même c'est à dire que
il
valide un dispositif qu'il avait lui
même rejeté il y a
quelques semaines à mois et demi deux
mois et donc notre opposition
elle est
totale envers ce ce dispositif mis en
place aujourd'hui
parce que ce sont les plus fragiles qui
vont payer ceux qui font des contrats
bref
multiples qui changent d'entreprise
régulièrement etc
c'est eux qui vont payer le leu leu leu
leu leu le prix de ces économies alors
économie à quel niveau
on ne sait pas les chiffres et ce qu'on
sait c'est que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros
sont investis dans le plan de relance
plusieurs centaines de milliards d'euros
ont été déversés sans contrepartie dans
les entreprises pendant la
crise sanitaire
et aujourd'hui on fait payer
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté
le conseil d'état a estimé que l'état
actuel du marché de l'emploi ne
constitue plus un obstacle à la mise en
place de la réforme et cette mise en
place de la réforme qui a été validé par
sa plus haute juridiction administrative
comment selon vous se porte ce marché de
l'emploi aujourd'hui
bien c'est à des éléments surprise de
ces décisions c'est à dire que nous ne
pensions pas que pour céder tôt
devait se prononcer sur des éléments
conjoncturels
forcément variable
le conseil des toits d'état doit se
prononcer sur le droit et sur le fond
comment se fait-il que le conseil d'état
aujourd'hui dit le marché de l'emploi va
mieux
donc on peut valider quelque chose qu'on
a invalidé il y a deux mois qu'il se
prononcer sur le fond de cette réforme
je serai
bien venu mais bon pour l'instant
il est nommé en attendant le conseil
d'état a autorisé quelque chose qu'il
avait interdit il y a deux mois et nous
ne comprenons pas ce qui a changé depuis
deux mois
qu'on nous dise le marché de l'emploi se
porte bien
eh bien il faut pas être demandeur
d'emploi par le penser parce que
très honnêtement aujourd'hui les
demandeurs d'emploi n'arrive pas à
trouver un emploi
donc
il y aborde la ministre du travail
estime elle que cette mesure va
encourager le retour au travail au
moment où notre économie repart on
évoque aussi une pénurie demandeurs
certains secteurs elle n'arrive pas à
recruter comment est-ce que vous recevez
ces arguments
alors ces arguments sont
pour une bonne partie exor
effectivement il ya des secteurs qui
peine à retrouver à trouver de la main
d'oeuvre et c
est pour une simple et bonne raison il
paye mal leurs salariés et donc ils
n'ont pas ils n'arrivent pas à attirer
des salariés
quand on demande à des gens de
travailler comme douala dans la
restauration etc jusque 48 heures dans
la semaine
en courant
et tout ça pour un smic et sans payer
des heures supplémentaires
il n'y a pas de candidat
dans le bâtiment c'est pareil le
problème aujourd'hui c'est les salaires
et les salaires nous on connaît ce
problème à la sncf aujourd'hui à la sncf
ça fait dix ans que les salaires sont
bloqués et la sncf n'arrive pas recruté
de madère mais parce que les salaires
sont bloqués depuis dix ans donc
aujourd'hui on a par exemple nous les
salariés de la surveillance générale
autrement dit la police ferroviaire
qui préfère
démissionner
passer des concours de par exemple la
police municipale
pour avoir un statut et un meilleur
salaire est plutôt que rester sncf donc
le problème
c'est des conditions de travail les
statuts et les salaires mais ça on ne le
traite pas
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagir sur notre
antenne daniel ferté je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général adjoint fo
cheminots